les annonces du chef de l'état ont été
accueillis on peut le dire dans un
climat de scepticisme est ce que vous
vous êtes convaincus par le plan emploi
de françois hollande
écoutez la première chose c'est que je
pense extrêmement important que ce plan
était présenté et que la mobilisation de
ce gouvernement soit vraiment sur
l'emploi je pense qu'il y avait une
urgence et je regrette moi que ça a été
plutôt qu' on est des propositions de la
sorte après vous l'avais dit il ya un
scepticisme parce qu'en fait il ya un
peu de tout dans ce plan là et je pense
qu'en même temps
moi j'attends d'un gouvernement quel
qu'il soit d'ailleurs qu'ils ne visent
très forte auprès des personnes qui sont
en recherche d'emploi qui sont inquiètes
pour le maintien de leur emploi quand
ils en ont moins
donc tout ce qui est annoncé sur la
formation me semble extrêmement
important parce qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup
de personnes ont du mal à changer
d'emploi ou en prendre un pour des
problèmes de défaillance de formation ne
découvre pas aujourd'hui oui mais je
pense qu'il ya si vous voulez c'est pas
une recette sur la formation vous faites
une fois que tout va bien à la
population active elle bouge les
demandes des professions bouge aussi le
métier du bâtiment d'aujourd'hui n'est
pas celui d'hier le métier du numérique
n'existait pas il ya quelques années
donc c'est quelque chose en mouvement il
est normal de s'adapter et donc d'aller
aussi vers des filières où il ya des
besoins très fort en emploi des besoins
de formation des bons de notation après
l'autre chose c'est qu'on revient tous
même s'il ya l'autre grande mesure qui
est la question des aides en 2011 pour
la création de 2000 euros et la création
d'emplois à des niveaux à peu près liés
au smic
et là la grande difficulté c'est qu'on
revient un peu au débat qu'on a depuis
en fait cinq ans notamment sur le cic et
sur d'autres mesures c'était tout le
temps sur des mesures macro on est tous
le monde alors que la question à
laquelle j'aimerais qu'un moment nous
répondent en particulier monsieur gattaz
ils sont où les 1 million d'emplois qui
nous a promis il ya eu cic il ya eu pas
mal de responsabilités ya le pacte de
stabilité il ya eu beaucoup des deux
entreprises
ça a été fait nous en avons à l'époque
nous dit qu'il n'y avait aucune
conditionnalité à ces aides et c'était
un problème vous estimez que le patronat
tarder
j'estime ne pas trop non d'après les
études de fc2 d'autres études qui ont
été montrées a pu reconstituer ses
marges de man beaucoup d'entreprises
vont mieux
elles ont pu retrouver une santé
financière même redonner des marges de
manoeuvre à leurs actionnaires
par contre les sujets sur lesquels nous
étions qui était est-ce que vous allez
créer des emplois ce que vous allez
pérenniser les emplois est ce que vous
en profitez pour améliorer les salaires
versés sont des sujets sur lesquels le
patronat ne jamais aller donner encore
jules offensive qui était la semaine
dernière d'avoir un nouveau contrat de
travail et donc ne jamais répondre à la
question qui est posée c'est puisque
vous dites vous cette entreprise que
vous êtes les moteurs la création
d'emplois donnez nous des réponses à
cette création là et c'est pour ça qu'à
un moment je pense quand même que l'état
doit aussi un moment posé des conditions
aujourd'hui vous réclamer des comptes au
patronat on réclame des comptes et y
compris de comprendre pourquoi les
accords de branche ont été si peu
nombreux pourquoi où sont les emplois
corps et de votre crédit ou cice qu'est
ce qu'ils ont fait de cet argent c'est
quand même beaucoup d'argent
plusieurs milliards d'euros sur
plusieurs années donc je pense qu'ils
ont des comptes à rendre
où sont les écrasent les et que les
emplois qu'ils voulaient créer sur les
territoires et c'est pour ça que j'en
viens aux compositions on a eu la cote
21 il ya maintenant un mois qui
aujourd'hui mais des engagements des
états sur la question du dérèglement
climatique qui veut dire derrière des
évolutions dans notre manière de
consommer de se développer de d'être
mobile et donc notamment de voyager dans
notre pays ça veut dire aussi derrière
des emplois locaux et la question est ce
que demain on a dans ce pôle emploi une
déclinaison de ces engagements la jean
marie le guen qui était à votre place
la semaine dernière qui s'interrogeait
sur la dégressivité des z oui sur leur
durée également alors vous répondez quoi
vos j'aime beaucoup les états d'âme de
parlementaires qui sont en place depuis
plusieurs dizaines d'années et qui n'ont
jamais connu la perte de l'emploi comme
monsieur le guen et je vais vous dire la
réalité aujourd'hui c'est que quand de
parler du chômage on s'en prend aux
systèmes d'indemnisation en estimant
qu'il est trop coûteux et des systèmes
élections parce qu elle pas dans le foie
le système peut-être est-ce que c'est
quoi la solution c'est qu'on laisse les
gens à la rue c'est qu'on dise aux gens
demain vous n'avez pas la banalisation
la réalité c'est que beaucoup de
chômeurs qui ne touche pas plus souvent
de 56% 60% de leur salaire antérieur net
sont dans des grandes difficultés
financières se retrouvent en difficulté
y compris de payer des loyers de nourrir
leurs familles et beaucoup de saisons la
demande d emploi
vous savez je termine une campagne
électorale
j'avais une équipe de campagne dont
l'ensemble de cette équipe est
aujourd'hui au chômage j'ai eu hier mon
ancien directeur de campagne qui m'a
raconté sa visite à pôle emploi avec une
question toute simple
crois tu vraiment qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
peut s'occuper de moi quand j'avais un
pôle emploi ce n'est pas le cas il n'y a
pas assez d'agents pour travailler
auprès des salariés diplômés ou pas il
n'y a pas assez d'argent pour travailler
auprès des jeunes et donc si on veut
vraiment réformer la banalisation du
chômage travaillons pour mettre plus
d'efforts sur le chômage et d'arrêter de
toujours vouloir taper sur les chansons
ne touchent pas vous dire on est tous
pas et sur ne touche pas et surtout
s'implique sur la vie des chemins il ya
des claques administrative terrible il
ya des années reste on reste sur la
réforme éventuelle messieurs non c'est
pas que c'est intéressant c'est que j'en
ai assez dans ce pays et c'était déjà le
cas avec monsieur rebsamen qu'à chaque
fois qu'on parle du chômage c'est pour
taper sur les chômeurs et
l'indemnisation et le jamais se poser la
question de savoir comment est ce que
cette période là efficace y compris par
lui et utile vous êtes sûrs t
aujourd'hui c'est pas d'unité de gauche
quand on vous entend à cette année c'est
pas niçois d'unités bdd de gauche vous
savez j'ai fait de la politique et
j'étais aussi dans le monde du travail
j'ai connu des licenciements j'ai connu
des dépôts de bilan je sais ce que c'est
je sais ce que c'est d'aller expliquer
sa vie à un agent un pôle emploi qui ne
comprend rien de ce que vous faites
parce qu'il ne connaît pas votre métier
et qui vaut dit débrouillez vous
c'est la réalité de beaucoup de gens
donc c'est très bien les formations je
pense que c'est très bien aussi son
amène plus des aides aux salariés
c'est pôle emploi c'est d'état de
réseaux qui aujourd'hui mobilise les
jeunes les plus vieux les seniors les
cadres sur la question de l'emploi
mais arrêtons d'avoir cette recette
facile à droite comme à gauche qui est
de penser qu'il faut taper sur l'unité à
gauche vous l'a dit alors à gauche c'est
le même françois hollande c'est jean
marie le guen on sait que c'est aussi
une idée partagée par manuel valls a eu
beau mettre en pétard mais sait pas qui
met en pétard je pense que c'est pas la
solution et que c'est pas en rognant sur
des indemnités qui sont pas énormes dans
ce pays et qu'on va répondre
la cour des comptes appelle calcule
ainsi en rogne comme vous l'êtes
effectivement parce que ça revient on
allège le sort de la cour des comptes
fasse aussi le calcul après de ce que
veut dire de m prise aux gens dans la
pauvreté et comme ils vont coûter à
l'état
combien coûterait les impayés augmenter
le loyer parce que des gens n'ont plus
leurs indemnités chômage
combien ça coûterait que des gens ne
payent plus leur pension alimentaire ne
payent plus leurs impôts etc etc
le chômage il a un coût c'est pour ça
qu'il faut se battre contre le chômage
et pas contre les chômeurs gens sur le
sujet de la déchéance de nationalité je
sais pas si c'est un piège mais c'est
surtout le fait que c'est un piège pour
aujourd'hui pour coutume il a voulu
peut-être à la droite gauche vous savez
moi je suis très premier degré dans la
vie je suis pas dans la posture je pense
comment commencer des choix politiques
faut les assumer jusqu'au bout
le président de la république a fait le
choix de présenter cette mesure qui est
pour moi un non sens et une
incompréhension totale et ce qui est
certain c'est que le 23 décembre corse a
été annoncé on nous a expliqué qu'en
gros les quelques personnes comme moi et
d'autres qui est se disaient contre nous
nous égarons si je me souviens bien
l'expression du premier ministre
la réalité c'est que cette proposition
fait du mal elle fait du mal dans la
société que le débat politique continue
perdure et que j'espère surtout que le
présent d'un public va voir la
clairvoyance de vous positionner mais il
va pas enlever la déchéance de
nationalité il a produit là il a
prononcé la formule devant le congrès il
a souhaité rencontrer
des groupes parlementaires et partis
politiques vendredi donc je ne sais pas
pour quelle caisse qui voudra nous dire
maintenant on cherche une solution
vraiment il n'ya pas de solution la
question qui va le plus mais ce qui est
terrible avec la déchéance de
nationalité c'est que vous expliquez que
sa nationalité c'est ce qui va nous
différencier et c'est ça le problème
quand vous dites que la république est
une et indivisible
la construction de notre état s'est fait
sur des grands principes et c'est ce qui
fait tout sommes un grand pays et c'est
pour ça que je pense que c'est une
erreur d'avoir été là bas là dedans
maintenant des expressions ont été
émises depuis décembre pour trouver une
porte de sortie différente indignité
nationale par exemple aux autres sujets
en tout cas les portes ont été fermées
par le gouvernement à chaque fois ce qui
est certain c'est qu'il ya eu la fameuse
formule prononcée devant le congrès un
des changes mais je vous salue
l'intelligence est de savoir reconnaître
quand on a pu faire une erreur ou quand
on veut évoluer
il semble que des candidats écologistes
se prépare à une éventuelle candidature
en 2017 ça ça se dit ça se sait
est ce que ça veut dire que si jamais
cette primaire n'a pas lieu
il pourrait y avoir un candidat
écologiste qui se présenterait donc face
à françois hollande peut-être face à
jean luc mélenchon
en tout cas c'est c'est un débat que le
parti au lendemain des excuses jeunes
n'avaient pas encore ouvert mais vous le
savez on a un congrès dans la fin du
sommet cela en juin et pour moi ce sera
un débat qui aura lieu à ce moment là
avant le congrès où certainement juste
après en tout cas ça fait partie des
échéances pour n'importe quel parti
politique de s'interroger sur ces choix
là y compris comme comme comme notre
parti et voyez vous comme candidat je le
peux vous demander de trancher mais non
mais déjà le dis très clairement et je
les dis au delà même parce que je pense
que le problème c'est pas qu'une
histoire de candidature de partie il
faut aujourd'hui être capable d'avoir
des candidats qui sont capables de
parler à la société toute entière
et moi j'ai dit je pense qu'elle que
trois personnes c'est qu'ils portent
l'écologie de manière extrêmement large
et cécile duflot c'est nicolas hulot et
c'est daniel cohn bendit ça veut pas
dire qu'ils sont candidats qu'ils sont
partants je vous dis à mes yeux les gens
qui aujourd'hui ont cette capacité à
aller avoir un projet politique qui
embrase largement la famille politique
mais qui va bien au delà on vous dit
en 30 dans le gouvernement oui à
l'occasion d'un remaniement au niveau
des pêches oui est ce que est ce que
vous avez été approché est-ce que vous
réfléchissez ce que vous savez déjà que
vous y allez vous n'y allez pas je je je
peux vous dire en tout cas donné tout ce
que je lis dans la presse y compris dans
vos dépêche ne vient ni de moi et non je
n'ai pas des rendez-vous à l'elysée pour
décider de mon avenir ministériel
je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est assez
intéressant d'ailleurs de voir comment
cette cette sauce la montre quand on a
un débat politique essentielle qu'est ce
que des déchéances de nationalité et que
tout le monde va essayer de l'enterrer
ce débat là ne va pas être enterré on
peut trouver des subterfuges il ya eu le
plan poids il ya ces rumeurs de
remaniement tout le monde ce qui
s'excitent ou savons que c'est une
fausse rumeur que ça veut dire ça
démontre que je ne suis pas ce n'est pas
le sujet et comme si on vous proposait
d'entrer dans le gouvernement
aujourd'hui que diriez vous je dirais je
pense que je vous ai déjà répondu à
plusieurs reprises pour quoi faire pour
casser la question vous demande
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est ce que vous
voulez faire dans la douleur la fin de
mandature
quels sont les projets de ce
gouvernement
est ce que vraiment vous voulez faire
une politique très écolo qui répond
notamment aux besoins de création
d'emplois est ce que l'on ferme notre
dame des landes est ce que l'on ce que
l'on arrête notre dame des landes est ce
que l'on ferme sessenheim ayons les
vrais débats et des bas mais vous feriez
le dialogue vous ne verriez par exemple
comme cécile duflot il n'avait pas
question avec manuel valls premier
ministre mais ça n'a jamais été la
position que j'ai tenus de
l'international j'ai toujours voulu
avoir une discussion politique et un
moment il faut arrêter entre les rumeurs
sur des remaniements et le fait que à
chaque fois il n'y a pas de discussions
politiques qu'elles sont très simples
renault reconnaît une erreur faute
avouée à moitié pardonnée
non non non je crois que ce qui se passe
c'est extrêmement grave et au moins on
peut se féliciter que y ait cette
commission mise en place très rapidement
presque en volkswagen où on a obtenu que
tout de suite soit tester des véhicules
français parce qu'au départ c'était pas
vraiment le cas et la réalité en tout
cas les informations que moi j'ai pu
obtenir c'est que semble-t-il iliad et
donc des défaillances sur les véhicules
renault sur des systèmes de dépollution
qui ne fonctionne pas à la ministre
vient de le dire ça ne fonctionne pas en
dessous de 17 degrés et objets pas que
renault il ya d'autres constructeurs
recrée dans les bribes en effet que j'ai
lu il y aurait il compris d'autres
constructeurs qu'on nous dit étrangers
mais attention dans mon souvenir n'a été
testé que 22 ou 25 véhicules sur une
centaine est ce qu'ils vont tous montés
en tout cas ce qui se raconte
cki compris dans les tests qui sont
faits à l'étranger dans d'autres pays où
les mêmes commissions ont été mises en
place c'est qu'on retrouve les mêmes
défaillances chez plusieurs
constructeurs et que semble-t-il ce qui
a été dit aux consommateurs les achètent
leurs voitures sur le respect la forme
de normes et tout ça son faux qui a
peut-être tromperie donc c'est
extrêmement grave qu en train de se
passer et je vais vous dire pourquoi je
trouve ça grave je trouve ça grave parce
qu'on trompe le consommateur et y
compris on trompe les autorités sur la
question de la pollution mais ce qui
m'inquiète le plus c'est aujourd'hui la
venue de ces entreprises
on a des salariés à renault qui ont un
savoir faire renault est une grande
maison où l'état est en plus actionnaire
qui produit des véhicules de qualité
mais qui en train en fait de nous dire
que sur sa toute sa production diesel
il ya une erreur donc la question que je
pose est ce que renault là demain se
modernise et montre qu'en fait il n'y a
pas de véhicules diesel qui peuvent être
propre parce que moi ce que je
qu'on sauve c'est les emplois de renault
et donc c'est un enjeu majeur parce que
vous avez vu l'effondrement de la bourse
la semaine dernière et moi ce qui
m'inquiète c'est qu'on a l'impression
que renault n'est pas si inquiet du
sujet et l'on connaît et une erreur de
calibrage sur un modèle il rappelle
quinze mille véhicules auxquels on
réagit chose que je crois que le
problème va être beaucoup plus
importants qu'en savons les normes
on sait qu'on nous dit pas on nous dit
pas où je vais en scène c'est pour ça
que je voulais quelque chose de caché
c'est pour ça que je vous dis que moi
j'attends de voir les 100 véhicules
testés
parce que là on nous parle d'un vécu et
notamment les plus récents qu'en est il
des plus anciens pourquoi est-ce que
lier un problème est qu'on l'a pas vu
avant
est-ce que excusez moi de poser des
questions aussi triviale mais on
découvre cela à l'occasion de ces tests
est ce que donc renault savez où est ce
que c'est une erreur
tout le monde s'est trompé est ce que
vraiment dans la chaîne de direction n'y
a pas de sujet pourquoi est ce que c'est
si grave
renault en même temps contrairement à
peugeot a quand même réussi à rattraper
son retard sur les véhicules électriques
est en train de développer notamment un
véhicule qui marche plutôt bien il ya un
enjeu majeur parce que c'est parts de
marché là aujourd'hui en france et en
europe sont prises par des constructeurs
étrangers notamment asiatiques et donc
la question de savoir aussi c'est quoi
le modèle automobile pour leur sens si
on parle d'un petit peu de consommateurs
comme vous l'avez fait actuellement ou
terrier kouao français aujourd'hui on se
rappelle qu'au moment de volkswagen ya
eu des actions groupe très importantes
qui ont été menées il faudra même chose
en france il faudra faire pareil déjà
sur volkswagen ne sait pas si elles ont
eu lieu en tout cas moi je me rappelle
qu'il fait des déclarations d'intention
pour par les actions de groupe
il faudra en faire aussi sur renault
imaginez quand même que des personnes
s'endettent pour acheter un véhicule qui
est nécessaire souvent pour aller
travailler pour être mobile on leur dit
qu'en gros on leur a menti mais qu'en
plus ils vont pas pouvoir le vendre
le prix qu'ils ont acheté ou qui peuvent
en espérer c'est le cas pour les gens
qui ont des volkswagen et des seat et
tout ça c'est qu'aujourd'hui projets et
des actions parce qu'ils ne peuvent
faire faire de leur véhicule pire que ça
je suis sur des personnes ou stc
véhicule en pensant agir correctement
pour la planète en étant vraiment
citoyens de ce point de vue là on crut
un instant tel véhicule
il allait avoir à faire un effort
peut-être payer plus cher que le reste
ils ont été dupés mais sont des choses
en plus qui sont pas arrêtés donc ça
mérite réparation vous dites donc des
actions de gros contre un constructeur
samarie transparence année en groupes et
oui
et en plus excusez-moi l'état français
et l'état est actionnaire de peugeot on
a augmenté de renault pardo et depuis on
a augmenté notre part chez renault
l'état est donc stratège dans ces
conseils d'administration des timbres à
19 heures est ce que l'état est au
courant de cela en tant que membre du
conseil d'administration depuis quand at
il ses informations là semble-t-il
personne ne l'avait en tout cas à
l'environnement est ce que bercy les
avais et que fait l'état demain que fait
l'état l'administration de renault je ne
dis pas ça je dis que quand on est
stratège
quand on est un état stratège dans des
entreprises dans lesquelles on a des
participations
on peut pas simplement dire c'est un peu
grave y'a renault il ya peugeot il ya de
l'avenir ces emplois et l'autre chose
sur lequel je ne voudrais pas qu'on
oublie quand même le premier sujet qui
est que tout cela part de la question du
diesel
le choix fait par la france de
développer ce type de motorisation qui
est nocif pour notre santé qui coûtent
des milliards etc des rapports un
rapport sénatorial qui le montre qu'
aujourd'hui un impact sur la santé
publique
et moi je souhaite qu'on sauvegarde ne
sont pas de l'automobile donc comment on
fait pour qu'à voir la transparence et
ne pas répéter à l'avenir ces mêmes
erreurs juste avant qu'on vienne
justement sur le prix du pétrole est il
forcément du diesel je termine avec ce
point où commission denquête c'est
quelque chose que vous pourriez demander
de la part des élus verts par exemple
en tout cas je sais qu'aujourd'hui c'est
en réflexion parfait en tout cas il ya
cette première il ya cette commission là
mais je pense qu'il faut tout le monde
veut déjà le procès fin du processus et
donc les commissions d enquête
parlementaire
en tout cas je ne sais pas étonnant ce
qu'ils vont faire mais je sais que les
parlementaires présents il ya un seul
écologiste et socialiste et républicain
se demandent quelles doivent être les
suites parlementaire sur le sujet la
personne qui est actuellement en charge
de l'écologie doit se battre pour qu'il
y ait des arbitrages y compris sur la
prochaine loi de finances sur les
questions le violeur
elle se bat beaucoup elle se bat
beaucoup et qu'on prenne à vue sur des
sujets très environnementaux je pense
notamment à la question de
l'interdiction d'une d'une pollution
très forte dans les calanques de
marseille qui les lie à ce qu'on appelle
les boues rouges à lectra c'est
l'extraction des minerais ségolène royal
s'est battu jusqu'au bout et la
meilleure d'entre eux a perdu en tout
cas en tout cas elle sait de quoi elle
parle
elle a compris l écoute mais vous savez
dit même ce matin sur une radio pour ça
que j'ai quelques prime avec le
gouvernement c'est que j'ai un temps
d'avancé sur les sujets écologiques mais
parce qu elle les connaît puisqu'elle
est conscient de ce qu'on dit mais vous
savez moi j'ai aussi travaillé de
laurent fabius dans le cadre de l'accord
j'ai rencontré un homme qui
objectivement s'est mis halak au
maintien et au climat quand on apprécie
qu'on a commencé à prendre en charge et
qui a découvert des choses et qui m'a
dit un jour cette phrase tu sais
maintenant je vais dans des réunions et
j'enrage
quand personne ne comprend les impacts
du dérèglement climatique je lui ai dis
bienvenue au club découvre ce que ça
veut dire d'être écologiste merci
beaucoup et mac os merci maca michael et
donc la semaine prochaine c'est bruno
retailleau qui sera votre place le
patron des sénateurs les républicains en
sera tout ça très vite
du coup